des repas gratuits distribués aux plus
démunis à l'église saint-eustache dans
le quartier des halles à paris les
distributions ont repris cette semaine
pour la première fois le diocèse et la
mérite paris mène une action commune
pour venir en aide aux sans abri la
ville finance les repas le diocèse les
distribuer
le centre de paris et le plus le plus
gros c'est à dire c'est 250 personnes
par jour quoi en gros qui ont besoin
encore une fois soit des gens dans la
rue c'est la majorité parce qu'ici il ya
les des souterrains il ya des tas de
souterrains donc qui a une population
souterraine dans ce quartier et puis des
gens qui sont seuls chez eux tout
simplement et qui n'ont pas de revenus
donc qui viennent aussi chercher leur
évidemment et on vous faire aucune
différence
ceux qui viennent prendre un sac près
d'un sac et puis voilà quoi le
confinement ajoutent d'autres problèmes
aux sans domicile fixe les sdf difficile
de faire la manche quand il n'y a plus
personne dans la rue impossible de
simplement prendre un café au chaud
puisque tous les bistrots sont fermés
c'est dur très dur
rigueur porto rigueur oui de décrire un
petit même aux difficultés évoquées
notamment ont fait la manche ont fait la
main pour un peu d'argent des cigarettes
une cigarette
les rouges et un peu tout ya eu un petit
garage et un peu dérangé du viennent
encore jean paris voilà sans rien du
tout le ministère du logement a annoncé
l'ouverture de 5000 places d'hébergement
supplémentaires dans des hôtels pour
accueillir les sdf
une mesure qui ne semble pas encore
suffisantes les talibés et 5000 chambres
d'hôtel pour moi je vois toujours tout
le monde dans la rue à dormir dans la
rue
pareil à l'heureux s'est passé qui
commet dans les chambres moi je vois
personne de ma connaissance je vois
personne autre problème le respect de la
distanciation sociales et des
gestes-barrières impossible à appliquer
de nombreux wc publics sont ainsi fermé
en vivant dans la rue les sans abri
reste donc particulièrement exposés au
virus
oui dans paris on là ils ont tout de
suite dit bon les gens de la rue on les
laisse dans la rue ils ont toutes façons
nulle part où aller
donc qu'ils restent dans les coins on
connaît les coins et ont sauvé face et
c'est ce que j'ai entendu dire on
surveille que ça se passe bien comme le
problème c'est que ces descoings
contaminants évidemment fin y dorment
dans les souterrains ici dit dom
ils font pas un mètre de distance entre
40 sites de confinement sont
actuellement prêts à accueillir les sans
domiciles touché par le coronavirus
selon le ministère du logement
il y aurait pour l'instant un peu plus
de 600 cadres sdf contaminées dans toute
la france selon le ministère